We're here in Athlone and we have just selected to see
two Phinegail
candidates for the Midlands Northwest European constituency.
Here's more about them. Hi,
I'm Maria Walsh, MEP and I'm seeking reelection on June 7th.
Three key priorities for me are a thriving rural economy,
making sure our small families,
farm families are getting all the support they need
and ensuring our SMEs are also getting that support.
Incredibly important. I'm Nina Carbrey
and I'm running in this year's European elections
for the Midlands North West constituency,
and my priorities are rural development,
opportunity and education
and reducing red tape for farmers.
I'm really looking forward to getting to work on these campaigns.
For more information on these brilliant candidates,
Nina and Maria, go to Finnoway.